[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está lista en el
estudio daniela hablando con daniela ya
viernes feliz mañana nos vamos a
descansar el fin de semana y pues vamos
a hablar de los precios que están
disparados hablamos esta semana y ayer
de américa latina pero en esta
oportunidad nos vamos al norte de
nuestro continente a eeuu ahí también ha
disparado los precios así es raúl muy
buenos días un feliz viernes para
ustedes ya que no tiene muchos planes
entonces descansen ahora pues mire la
inflación en eeuu en decir en enero de
este año del 7.5 por ciento interanual
eso quiere decir enero frente a enero
del año pasado y quiere decir también
que subió en cinco décimas frente a
diciembre cuando era del 7% ahora eso
quiere decir que se aceleró el nivel de
precios y lo que hace es que el mercado
ya dé por descontado que va a haber una
subida de tasas de interés en la próxima
reunión de marzo ahora la pregunta es de
cuánto será ese aumento pues en todo lo
que va de la pandemia ese tipo de
interés raúl se ha mantenido en un cero
por ciento qué significa esto daniela en
términos económicos para la economía del
país
vamos a volver a explicarlo como siempre
porque es importante que los
televidentes entiendan la misión
principal de los bancos centrales es que
la inflación se mantenga baja y estable
con un buen crecimiento económico y
desde luego conservando los empleos y la
herramienta principal es la tasa de
interés cuando estas muy baja el consumo
se dispara y eso a su vez hace que
aumenten los precios la tarea de la
reserva federal en este caso es buscar
el equilibrio por ejemplo aumentando un
poco ese tipo de interés para que los
precios de bienes y servicios pues se
estabilice danny estamos hablando de la
inflación de los precios disparados pero
ahora la solución como se están
combatiendo este fenómeno de los altos
precios en la región pues subiendo tasas
de interés ya los bancos centrales han
empezado a hacerlo desde meses atrás
méxico por ejemplo lo acaba de subir al
6% una de las tasas más altas de la
región perú la elevó ayer por séptimo
mes consecutivo y muchos países de
américa latina están en esa misma
tendencia falta solamente eeuu que dicen
que está rezagado y con esta volatilidad
del mercado esta inflación le pregunta
entonces cómo están los dos mire los
mercados se mueven al ritmo de eeuu por
supuesto asia-pacífico registró pérdidas
en las bolsas de hong kong australia
seúl y shanghái y en europa las bolsas
registran descensos siguiendo los pasos
de wall street cuyos principales índices
se hundieron en la jornada anterior
volvemos a eeuu daniel al
específicamente el estado de california
donde acusan a tesla de discriminación
racial porque pues miren señalan a la
empresa del multimillonario y lo en más
que de discriminar a los empleados
negros de su fábrica en fremont que
queda muy cerca de la bahía de san
francisco donde produce la gran mayoría
de sus autos el departamento de vivienda
y empleo justo de california presentó
una demanda ante el tribunal superior
del condado de alameda alega que ha
recibido cientos de quejas y dice que
encontró evidencia de que este es un
lugar de trabajo segregado racialmente
como lo denuncia el abogado de los
empleados
y una de las cosas que hemos visto es
que esta es una cultura y un entorno
increíblemente tóxicos en el que
trabajan muchos de estos empleados donde
hay acoso sexual acoso racial y
discriminación y ciertamente hemos visto
evidencia de todos y en el caso de las
mujeres de color han experimentado la
intersección alidad y el acoso en todas
sus formas
también hay que darle la palabra t es la
que calificó la demanda de injusta y
contraproducente vamos ahora a
centroamérica daniel salvador al
salvador le redujeron la calificación
crediticia por qué pasó esto pues lo
hizo fitch ratings que es una de las
calificadoras de riesgo más importantes
del mundo las otras son standard and
poor's y moody's esa agencia de
calificación de riesgo dice que la
medida que en septiembre convirtió al
salvador en el primer país del mundo en
darle uso legal al bitcoin creó
incertidumbre porque el bitcoin no es
respaldado por el resto de autoridades
monetarias del mundo y su altísima
volatilidad representa un riesgo según
el fondo monetario internacional
qué significa todo esto para el país
pues quiere decir que al salvador le van
a hacer más difícil conseguir
financiamiento externo básicamente el
gobierno está negociando hoy un programa
de 1300 millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional y ese organismo
ha hecho varios llamados al presidente
nadie bukele para que reconsidere su
posición sobre el bitcoin pero además
también hay otras razones que esgrimió
fitch para bajar la nota y es el
debilitamiento de las instituciones la
concentración del poder en la
presidencia y también el elevado déficit
fiscal se adivine que va a ser el fondo
monetario internacional pues así es
daniela vamos ahora con la cifra el día
para finalizar nuestro primer bloque
económico de nuestro programa 'aula
ustedes a twitter sí señora yo también
para informarme no tanto para ello
también yo más ciento de reto y todo
cosas de nuestro programa el canal pero
pues no escribo mucho de enseñar con las
cifras son los 217 millones de usuarios
monetizables diarios con los que cerró
twitter en 2021 puede sonar muy extraño
pero eso lo que quiere decir es que sólo
son aquellos que ven los anuncios del
día 217 millones que es muy poco
crecieron 13% pero no están cumpliendo
las metas de la empresa y hay que decir
que facebook reportó recientemente que
por primera vez en la historia había
perdido de usuarios y reconoció que es
porque hay otras plataformas 'tik tok'
entre ellas me encanta tanto
daniela gracias entonces por toda la
información de economía vamos ahora a
ver nuestro reportaje